Hanabi says his home in Hosny province
was destroyed by one of the more than
7400 bombs the US Air Force dropped out
of honnest on last year US government
data suggests it is the highest total of
air strikes in Afghanistan in ten years
his family's home in the village of
Tucson became a US target during a
battle between the Taliban and
government forces it was 12:30 at night
when the airplane bombed our house it
was the day act district and a lot of
fighting was going on my brother was
killed along with three of his daughters
one was four years old one was two years
old and the third one was six months old
fighting came as close as 50 meters to
his house after what he describes as a
drone strike nubbie moved surviving
members of his family to Ghazni the
capital of the province they returned
last month after repairs to their mud
house nubbie points to where the bomb
struck he says he found his brother
Muhammad of zou and three of his
brothers children in pieces a drone
bombed our house I lost my husband and
three children I don't know where the
Taliban came from and started fighting
that an airplane came and hit our house
we're in trouble and I am
psychologically traumatized my children
get scared my nieces and nephews get
scared our whole family is scared now
when they hear loud noises the children
say the drones have come back one of us
those daughters survived the attack when
asked where her father is she says in
the airplane and that her uncle takes
care of her for now her answer suggests
she still doesn't fully comprehend what
happened an airstrike in but peace
province in the north of the country
earlier this month meant for the Taliban
locals say killed only civilians mana
the forever
last night three bodies came to a
hospital two children and one woman they
were all dead
three more children died on the spot and
the local villagers buried them there
the latest report from us monitors says
last year American and Afghan forces
killed more civilians than the Taliban
for the first time since the conflict
began and you
US officials monitoring reconstruction
efforts also found that Taliban and
other armed groups carried out more
attacks in the last quarter of 2019 than
at any time in the previous decade
fighting during this time of year
usually moves from snow-covered mountain
terrain to warmer urban centers but this
time there's been more violence in rural
communities and relative quiet in major
cities that is attributed to peace talks
with the Taliban US diplomats are hoping
an agreement described as a reduction in
violence will help bring American troops
home winding down the war in Afghanistan
is something Donald Trump knows could
help his reelection campaign but
fighting has continued outside major
cities the number of people being killed
in provincial districts has continued to
rise if the latest round of Taliban
talks fail Afghans worried that the next
fighting season due to start in the
spring a matter of months could be more
violent than ever
zanoits ravi al jazeera Kabul